this subliminal messaging DGI yeah
thanks racist Friday welcome to another
Friday video on my channel my name is
grace Helbig if you did not know now you
know your life is different now am I
trying to make that a thing well by now
for this thank grace it's Friday I
thought it would be wonderful to connect
with you guys and comment on your
comment so let's do that
is that my costume is worst mime ever
thank you
let's start over on Facebook yep it's
like this spam Stolte new person to
person to person probably nickname and
getting really good at music so if you
would subscribe to that that would be
great for all of you that do not know if
a new person comments and one of my
social media platforms I graced the crap
out of them and walk on them to this
stuff am Sam stump team or like Nick
Nolte someone did not do the best job in
the witness protection program renaming
you Nick Nolte Sam stall T I see right
through that
who is Nick Nolte actor or baseball
player literally that's the question I
oppose to any person that is presented
to me with name I don't know you've been
great how you been grace you know I
appreciate what I'm reading as
genuineness in this question I've been
good I'm not the worst I'm not the best
staying positive emotionally and not
positive STD Ellie why don't you write
that out in a really beautiful cursive
fun put it on the Pinterest Chelsea
Brown new person to person to person
Kelsey brown more like Kelsey turned
that Brown upside down is what
astronauts say to each other when they
have to take a [ __ ] in space your my
words catching up with not too deep as I
am so far behind don't worry I love a
far behind the last thing I want is a
but right up in my face did you stumble
onto a construction site or a YouTube
channel because I'm nailing
this also I hope you do catch up because
I love this like quote season of not too
deep every episode was so fun to record
and everyone was so interesting and the
personalities it's just a spectrum of
wonderful people so haven't caught up on
this season of not too deep I really
encourage you to there's links in the
description box below
please go listen now let's go over to
Twitter hashtag shenanigans
central Lance Nye gamer guy new person
to person to person laughs my gamer guy
more like I like to read this name like
Lance nine gam or guy like is he a gam
like is he just like a human leg or T a
guy you've been great like 90% certain I
just ran into grace Helbig on the red
line today
either that or clone a really good clone
unless you have a nickname for my house
called the red line that I don't know
about um then I probably wasn't on the
red line that you are referring to but I
am on my monthly red line kcs be mighty
to person to person to person kcs PYT
more like I know that acronym stands for
obviously Keys cars shocks bicycles
YouTube titties and that of course is my
favorite Walt Whitman fellow your boo
boo thank you after a bad day you put a
smile on my face well that's all I'm
gonna put on your face because I don't
like touching other people's faces
Greyson name's joe person to person
person great some names more like
Grayson names she's been traveling so
much can you guys all tweet at memory
and just tell her to come back to the
United States and hang out with me
you're the group's catching up on not
too deep alone on the bus means I can
laugh out loud without feeling awkward
hey I relate to that you know who else
can laugh out loud
feeling awkward worst my mother thank
you one for catching up on not too deep
and two for taking this very staged
photo of yourself by yourself on a bus I
mean I've been there done that felt a
little bit like a serial killer
got through it and Here I am today in a
very casual body position now let's go
to YouTube ever heard of it yet here oh
I just thought I didn't like touching
faces cath lady new person to person to
person cath lady more like back baby
what a terrible superhero that would be
bath baby a baby with the power to give
itself a bath actually pretty good
you've been great I laughed way harder
at this than I should thank you for
thank you you should not laugh hard
thing as I make you get it you get you
get the kind of reaction that I want you
should feel so embarrassed that you left
a lot of my videos because that's not
what I try to do Mike Aflac new person
to person to person Mike Aflac more like
I see right through your witness
protection this is Ben Affleck wearing a
beanie pretending he's a One Direction
member you guys got to step up your game
you been good yeah it's great I like
this content Yas Ben Affleck in the
witness protection program Stan but I
like this respond to my content
everyone's happy Isabella's hat oh hold
on Isabella hat Keenan and shanem and
new person to person to person
Isabella hat Keenan and shin Ammon more
like Isabella hash
ma'am ma'am you look gross first what
happened since one of your videos
slightly helpful I don't know what
happened I gave advice that was useful I
know what isolator a lot of you and I
will try to never do that again
they're there they're dead they're there
they're there they're there that's it
for commenting on your comments to guys
I hope that you enjoyed this video if
you did please subscribe here's a button
you can click very conveniently to allow
yourself to subscribe to this channel if
that's something that you would enjoy I
know I would enjoy it other than that
have a wonderful weekend don't forget if
you would like to to check out all of
the full audio versions of not too deep
there's a link down below and make sure
that you check in on our writing with
grace series the newest episode went up
yesterday for those of you that have
been really engaged in writing this
novella with me so far it's been so
incredible if you haven't checked it out
yet I hope you do because even if you
don't want to participate it's really
fun to read everyone's submissions and
to get really angry about how talented
other people are in relation to your own
abilities I don't know
how would Beth baby wear a cape the Cape
would have to be like one of those
squeegees that like Olympic divers use
after they dive